Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Buon pomeriggio a tutti voi, terrestri.
Noi veniamo dal pianeta
"Atelier Dell'Errore",
costellazione della
neuropsichiatria infantile.
Siamo arrivati in questo bellissimo teatro
accompagnati da una carovana
di una trentina di grandi animali
che sono nati dal lavoro
del nostro "Laboratorio di arti visive
per la Neuropsichiatria Infantile".
Ci ha fatto da guida
questo bestione di due metri per tre,
che si chiama "Il tri-checo in-namorato".
Così ci ha insegnato Giovanni, in atelier.
Giovanni è un ragazzino importante,
nella storia dell'atelier,
perché lui, dodici anni fa,
a domanda precisa: "Dai Giovanni,
che facciamo un disegno!"
ha risposto, con altrettanta precisione:
"No, ma io non posso disegnare."
E "io non posso disegnare"
è diverso dal "io non so disegnare"
con la quale, credo,
la maggioranza di noi
riuscirebbe ad aggirare
la richiesta di un disegno qui e ora.
È il "tu non sai disegnare",
subito ad oltranza,
che dentro di lui diventa
"non posso disegnare".
Che è un auto-limitazione,
un'auto-mutilazione,
nella propria capacità
di leggere il mondo.
Eppure, lavorando in atelier
abbiamo scoperto, nel tempo,
che anche questa sorta
di diseducazione artistica,
questo abbandono grafico,
ha dei vantaggi.
Ha dei vantaggi rispetto
all'energia del segno,
alla forza espressiva.
E tutto questo è componente fondamentale
di un ambiente strutturato al servizio
della neuropsichiatria infantile.
E allo stesso tempo, è una ricchezza
anche per il mondo
delle arti visive tout court.
Per questo, da quel giorno
di dodici anni fa,
in atelier, segno dopo segno,
pomeriggio dopo pomeriggio,
in atelier abbiamo sempre disegnato.
Adesso tocca a Ayub.
Ayub ci ha abituati ad arrivare in atelier
con delle bellissime ragazzine
sul telefonino.
Ragazzine di cui si innamorava - diceva;
si fidanzava - diceva;
e poi lasciava - diceva.
Su questa potenza dell'innamoramento,
e del fidanzamento soprattutto,
i suoi compagni di gruppo, di lavoro
hanno cominciato ad avere dei dubbi.
Lui, per difendere la sua onorabilità,
un pomeriggio arriva in atelier e dice:
"Oggi sono stato lasciato io
da una delle mie ragazzine".
Ah.
"E quindi, oggi io non posso disegnare
perché mi sento triste come un canguro."
"Perché, sono tutti tristi
i canguri che conosci?"
"Ma no, non sono tutti tristi;
però esiste un canguro triste di cuore."
"Beh, perfetto, facci conoscere cos'è
il canguro triste di cuore."
Ecco, ci ha consegnato questa creatura
con un segno scarnificato, essenziale:
chirurgico, verrebbe da dire
con facile autoironia,
visto che Ayub porta in curriculum
una dozzina di operazioni alla testa,
certificate da altrettante cicatrici.
Però c'è anche il vantaggio di Ayub
che sa sempre sdrammatizzare,
infatti ammicca al suo pubblico
con un sorriso e un occhio furbo.
Il resto cos'è?
È un corpo-sacca,
a contenere l'enormità di un cuore
pieno di tutta la tristezza del mondo.
Non ha nemmeno bisogno
degli arti superiori:
poggia direttamente
sulla tristezza del proprio cuore.
I ragazzini ancora rilanciano,
provano a prendersi
ancora cura del nostro.
E gli dicono: "Va beh, Ayub,
potresti provare ad invitare
una di queste ragazzine
da McDonald una volta,
che a te piace tanto."
"Ma no, non posso: ci ho già provato.
Ma tutte le volte che mi trovo davanti
ad una di queste ragazzine
che a me piace
mi sento - divento una mosca timida
che non trova le parole."
Allora, "una mosca timida
che non trova le parole"
già di per sé è una poesia fatta e finita
nelle nominazione,
con quattro parole scorticate:
una sorta di Haiku oltrezoologico,
di quelli che succedono spesso in atelier,
nella nominazione di queste creature.
Quello che ci lascia è un moscoide,
mai apparso sulla faccia della Terra
fin dalla fondazione del mondo.
Una mosca che sembra proprio una mosca,
[ma] che non riuscirà mai a fare la mosca.
C'è sempre un taglio autobiografico
in tutte le creature dei ragazzini.
Adesso che avete, credo,
intuito come si guardano,
e soprattutto come si vedono
gli animali dell'atelier,
vi lascio in compagnia
del resto della carovana
mentre io vi racconto
un po' la nostra storia.
Io sono un artista visivo,
e da dodici anni
ho questo laboratorio di arti visive
per la Neuropsichiatria Infantile
della USL di Reggio Emilia,
e da tre anni anche per la
Neuropsichiatria Infantile Territoriale
dell'Azienda Ospedaliera di Bergamo.
In atelier arrivano ragazzini
con le patologie più svariate:
dai ritardi, più o meno gravi;
sindromi, disturbi -
disturbi anche questi dei più vari,
dai più semplici ai più complessi;
sindromi con dei nomi anche aggraziati,
che però lasciano delle conseguenze
abbastanza pesanti
sulle; vite dei ragazzini:
X-fragile, Tourette.
E anche qualcosa del famigerato
"contenitore dell'autismo",
mentre noi siamo un atelier
fondamentalmente strutturato
sulla narrazione, e sulla relazione,
quindi non sarebbe esattamente
roba da autistici:
però coltiviamo cinque o sei eccezioni
di cui siamo orgogliosissimi.
Del resto chi si sarebbe mai aspettato
che Arnuld Freiner,
uno dei più grandi pittori viventi,
abbia proprio invitato due
delle nostre ragazzine
ad inaugurare una mostra internazionale
a Monaco di Baviera, fra due settimane?
Siete già tutti invitati.
Diciamo che c'è
un minimo comune denominatore,
che lega tutte queste patologie;
e questo minimo comune denominatore,
centrato sull'autostima
e sulla socializzazione,
è anche il motivo per cui vengono inviati
in un atelier di arti visive
a complemento
della neuropsichiatria infantile.
L'autostima di questi ragazzini,
dei miei ragazzini,
è pressoché pari allo zero.
Sono quelli che mediamente
fanno percorsi marginali,
nella didattica della scuola.
Però, lavorando sempre,
con delle iniezioni di energia
da risollevare degli elefanti,
con tanto tempo, da tanti percorsi,
uno diverso dall'altro,
con tante sfide, sfide di tutti i giorni,
sfide soprattutto per loro stessi,
fra loro stessi.
Tante scommesse: su ognuno di loro
c'è una piccola scommessa.
Il lavoro comincia a dare
delle gratificazioni,
il lavoro impostato con una certa serietà.
E aumenta la quantità del lavoro,
con la soddisfazione;
aumenta anche la qualità, del lavoro.
Cominciano le prime mostre,
cominciano i primi inviti,
un po' di libri;
e loro?
Loro si ri-animano.
Non so, vi immaginate
uno di questi ragazzini,
che mediamente bivacca
con l'insegnante di sostegno a scuola,
che arriva un giorno e dice:
"Professoressa,
questo è il nostro libro d'arte.
Vede? Parla di me, c'è il mio nome,
c'è il lavoro che io faccio
con i miei amici,
questo è il mio animale
di cui solo io so perché è così."
E magari l'abbiamo
appena presentato
al Festival della Letteratura di Ivrea,
è successo.
Oppure al festival di Bergamo Scienza,
pure è successo.
Oppure siamo andati
alla fiera di arte contemporanea
di Arte Verona:
"Sa, professoressa,
c'erano 200 persone ad aspettarci.
E noi ci siamo divertiti
ad andare sotto la nostra creatura
e vedere la faccia
di quegli sconosciuti
che han pagato cinque euro
per venire a vedere il nostro lavoro.
È così.
Ecco: questo tipo di esperienza personale,
questa gratificazione autentica,
è un po' il bene durevole
che deposita il lavoro in atelier
nella profondità di questi ragazzini.
Un bene durevole che, al di là di tutto,
mai nessuno al mondo
potrà loro portare via.
Per quanto riguarda la socializzazione
è ancora più semplice, dico:
"Scusate, voi come fate già a conoscervi
prima di arrivare in atelier?"
"Be', è facile: siamo quelli
dell'insegnante di sostegno."
Oppure:
"Siamo quelli che alle feste di compleanno
non vengono invitati mai."
Facilissimo.
Ma fin qui uno lo può intuire,
visto le problematicità.
La cosa che invece
mi ha sempre sorpreso
è il fatto che questa marginalità
aggancia spesso le famiglie,
e quindi c'è una deriva sociale
anche delle famiglie
dei ragazzini che hanno
queste problematiche.
E questo ci ha spinto, quattro anni fa,
a fondare un'associazione che si chiama
"Atelier Dell'Errore ONLUS",
che ha il compito di coinvolgere
i genitori in questo lavoro,
perché evidentemente non possono
venire in atelier: non ha senso.
Possono aiutarci a far conoscere, invece,
il lavoro dei loro figli in atelier.
Adesso vorrei raccontarvi
perché noi ci chiamiamo
"Atelier dell'Errore",
e perché siamo così orgogliosi
di questo nome.
l primo motivo deriva dal fatto
che il primo, e più grande,
errore in atelier
sono stato io,
nel senso che non è un lavoro
che ho scelto.
Adesso, dopo 12 anni,
posso dire con una certa serenità
che forse questo lavoro mi ha scelto.
Sono stato scelto dall'atelier,
e forse è per quello
che è venuto anche abbastanza bene.
Però io ho sofferto,
il primo anno in atelier:
ho provato il senso di inadeguatezza,
l'essere inadatto rispetto
alla complessità che non conosci,
la complessità di questi ragazzini:
e soprattutto, dal punto di vista
delle arti visive,
non avevo ancora intuito la profondità
e la ricchezza di un immaginario,
perché questo immaginario loro,
speciale, lo vedete,
sta sotto una stratificazione di sconfitte
che è difficile
da perforare, da trivellare.
Questo è il problema:
lasciare emergere alla luce del sole
questa ricchezza.
Ci ha aiutato, nel tempo,
la remora razzista, per esempio:
c'è l'affiorare di creature,
credo, strabilianti:
non tanto per l'impatto grafico,
ma per le storie,
per le storie che custodiscono.
E poi, se io mi sono sentito un errore
per un pomeriggio alla settimana,
ascoltando loro ho poi capito
che in effetti loro si sentono un errore
per sette giorni alla settimana,
quattro settimane al mese,
dodici mesi l'anno.
E questa consapevolezza
mi ha aiutato a fare
un salto qualitativo
sul mio sguardo interiore,
che è stato quello
di abbandonare, per un po',
la "normaloidità" del mio sguardo.
Far un salto di là
dove si stava dischiudendo questo mondo,
il mondo dell'atelier
dove impari, per esempio,
che il contrario
di "normale" è "speciale".
Il contrario di "guardare" è "vedere".
Il contrario di "ascoltare" è "sentire".
Questi sono stati i primi due motivi
per cui noi siamo l'Atelier dell'Errore.
Il terzo invece è più metodologico:
la nostra non è una scuola di disegno,
siamo antiaccademici per definizione.
Sperimentiamo molto, quello sì.
E quindi, a me non interessa
che loro diventino dei disegnatori,
ma che prendano confidenza
sulla possibilità di diventare
originali, e originanti,
creatori di creature.
Questo vuol dire
che di fronte al foglio,
che raccoglie l'informe
dei primi segni fallimentari,
non ti arrendi, come sarebbe facile,
ma ti sforzi di guardare e riguardare
dove tutti guardano e pochi vedono,
che mi sembra un ottimo esercizio poetico.
E allora, parti da una zebra,
che inciampa e diventa una formica,
si rialza per diventare un drago
e poi, magari, finalmente
entra nell'inconosciuto,
uno di questi animali unici al mondo,
come unici al mondo siamo tutti noi,
a cominciare da loro.
Detto questo, pensandoci bene
se tutti noi non avessimo ereditato un DNA
capace non solo di generare errori,
di affrontarli, di superarli,
anche noi questa sera
saremmo, più o meno,
555 batteri ben allineati.
E questo è il terzo motivo
per cui noi siamo molto orgogliosi
di essere l'Atelier dell'Errore.
Adesso vorrei - spero
che sia di buon auspicio -
parlarvi del progetto
fondamentale di quest'anno.
Io ho cinque ragazzini che passano
dalla neuropsichiatria infantile
all'handicap adulto.
Purtroppo, l'handicap adulto
è mediamente terapia occupazionale,
esattamente l'opposto
di quello che noi facciamo in atelier.
Il problema è che,
se tu apri la testa a una persona,
non puoi pensare che dopo
questa la richiuda a comando.
E quindi c'è un disadattamento notevole,
nel passaggio con l'handicap adulto.
Quello che noi vogliamo fare
è costruire un gruppo di lavoro,
di formazione-lavoro.
Un'Alta Scuola di Arti Visive,
mi piacerebbe che diventasse,
per bambini che vengono
dalla Neuropsichiatria Infantile.
E che si autofinanzi
con operazioni tipo queste:
installazioni, opere urbane;
e anche grafica, editoria.
Se questa cosa ci riesce,
ecco, allora forse riusciamo a realizzare
una piccola, grande utopia sociale,
che è la quadratura
del cerchio del progetto -
sarebbe, forse, speriamo -
cioè quella di trasformare una criticità,
una problematicità sociale,
in una ricchezza,
una ricchezza sociale che è bellezza.
Bellezza è un termine, purtroppo,
che è stato esautorato
da un sacco di declinazioni.
Certamente non è la bellezza
autoreferenziale ed edonistica
del "è bello ciò che mi piace":
no, non è niente di tutto questo.
Non è neanche la bellezza, diciamo,
in qualche modo "cosmetica"
con cui ci tedia
il mondo della pubblicità.
È una bellezza che si rifà
a un nucleo ben più antico.
La bellezza come mediatore,
come mediazione verso il bene dell'uomo,
un bene da ricercare, da condividere.
Adesso facciamo un passo indietro
rispetto agli avanzamenti,
torniamo a due secoli fa,
alla bellezza definita
in maniera ancora perfetta
dal nostro caro principe Miskin
ne "L'idiota" di Dostoevskji:
la bellezza che salverà il mondo.
Noi a questa cosa, in atelier,
ci crediamo ancora.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)